yeah welcome I'm Nick lemon the Dean of
the Graduate School of Journalism here
however if you pay attention to this
sign in front of me on the lectern you
will note that this is a SEPA school of
international public affairs event in
partnership with the journalism school
which is contributing the space so
thanks to SEPA who's Dean John
cotesworth is sitting here and I'm just
going to introduce the moderator for the
evening and then go sit in the audience
the moderator is Alan Brinkley sitting
here he is Allan Nevins professor of
history at Columbia until the end of
last year was also Provost of Columbia
and has himself a new book out called
the publisher which is a biography of
Henry Luce that you're seeing reviewed
around so Alan no turn over to you and
welcome mark and John and I'll listen
with interests thank you Nick thank you
all for coming and it's a pleasure to
welcome John Hellman and Mark Halperin
here to Columbia and thanks to a Nick
and everyone who's helped organize this
event so this is a an event to discuss
the sensational a successful book game
change and of course these two men are
it's two authors and this book has
really broken a lot of new ground and
the way journalists deal with elections
and I we thought that this would be a
good thing to talk about with journalism
students and people interested in
journalism and so we're going to open
this up by giving each of the the
authors a chance to say a few words
about the book and
talk a little bit about what what
reactions they they want to react to and
then we'll have time for questions both
from me and from all of you so let me
introduce the two authors John Heilemann
on the left on my left here and John is
the national political correspondent and
a columnist for New York magazine he's
the author of pride before the fall the
trials of Bill Gates in the end of the
Microsoft era and of course he's the
co-author of Game Change Mark Halperin
is editor at large and senior political
analyst for Time magazine
and prior to that worked at ABC News for
nearly 20 years and he was a he received
his BA from Harvard and where it was in
a class of mine and it's nice to see him
again
so I think we'll start and let whichever
one of you wants to go first say a
little bit about your book and and
whenever you want whatever you want to
say about it okay thank you
the professor was not the worst grade I
got there so that's all you're all nice
to come and thanks to Nick into the both
both schools for hosting us well I'll
just talk briefly a little bit about
about the book as a piece of journalism
and and then John will talking and we'll
have to take questions that the reality
of of this book for us was a challenge
from its premise because the premise of
doing a book about a campaign these days
is considered questionable as a
commercial prospect and even as it as a
piece of journalism because we were
going to write about the most covered in
some ways over covered campaign any of
us had ever seen people were familiar
day to day minute by minute because it
was such a compelling story with both
plot and the characters and also
there was going to be more of it across
more platforms more media than there had
ever been the last few campaign cycles
had not seen a commercially successful
campaign book and so while we talked
about it separately in almost every
political reporter covering the race
whoever had aspirations to write a book
about noodling about what could be a
campaign book that would be successful
until we hit on the idea for Game Change
neither of us were planning to do a book
about the campaign and in fact what is
surprising in some ways given the
interest that people have had in our
book is there were very few other books
written fewer than 5 really of anything
like the type of book a chronicle of
what happened we're done almost all of
them all of them really came out before
ours and so the puzzle we faced really
it was a came up with the solution
before we really thought about the
challenge because as I said although we
both as most journalists had thought
about doing a book we thought about this
book as we were coming back from a
particularly pathetic and that's for
journalists fabulous John McCain event
where he performed very badly in a very
bad setting and we realized that this
was as we say in the subtitle of our
book the race of a lifetime that it did
have in fact an incredibly compelling
plot with with twists and turns but also
amazing characters our standing joke as
we wrote the book was if you've got a
presidential campaign where Rudy
Giuliani is the seventh most interesting
candidate you know you're covering a
pretty interesting presidential race and
this was a cast when we thought of the
book that did not include what
eventually would be one of the more
interesting characters Sarah Palin but
the Clintons and the Obamas and the
McCain's and and John and Elizabeth
Edwards all produced for us a sense that
if we focus on characters if we focus on
the candidates and their spouses rather
than the tactics and the strategy and
the polling and all the things that were
part of the day-to-day press coverage
that we might be able to produce a book
people would be interested in and that
the main animating premise for us
besides the characters was the notion
that there were big unanswered questions
about the race
questions that the two of us didn't know
the answers to even though we have
covered the race closely and consumed a
lot of media about the race
why did Barack Obama think he had a
chance to win what role did hillary
clinton play in our Bill Clinton planner
in his wife's campaign why did John
McCain pick Sarah Palin a question we
eventually grappled with and and in all
those areas we thought you know the
coverage of those questions was was was
not zero but those things were covered
those big questions were covered the way
everything was covered day to day much
the way to use the cliched metaphor that
way second graders play soccer someone
kicks the ball across the field and
every player runs around the ball so
you've got twenty players clustered
around the ball and then someone kicks
the ball out of the pack and everybody
chases after it and there's not a lot of
follow-through there's not a lot of
spreading out and trying to see the
whole field we thought we could do that
we thought we could go back to those
questions after everyone had moved on to
where the ball was after the election
and do a lot of interviews and try to
get to the bottom of the answers to
those questions again with a relentless
focus not on the strategists and tactics
and all the other things and not on
policy although we're both interested in
policy but on answering the fundamental
question what it became what problems to
the candidates and their spouses face
how did they feel about them and what
did they do about them and to do that to
try to write that we drew on what for
both of us were 20-year relationships
with people in both political parties
people who had stories to tell and we're
willing to tell them to us they weren't
interviews with over 300 interviews that
we did they weren't interviews that were
in almost any case combative or
difficult we sat down with the people we
were interviewing almost always together
almost always in person and we asked
them to tell us the stories of the
campaign and what was most fundamentally
different about this from the kind of
journalism that we had practiced now and
that is mostly practice and campaigns
and almost every thing else's we had the
luxury of re-interviewing people we had
the luxury of finishing an interview a
long interview and then saying to each
other
debriefing each other and saying well
this interview lead more than who are
the new people we didn't thought of to
interview that we now need to interview
who are the people we've already
interviewed that we need to go back to
and again if you think about daily
journalism on the web or in a newspaper
weekly or monthly journalism in a
magazine that's a luxury that doesn't
usually exist anymore and it's and it's
it is it is obviously qualitative
quantitatively different but it's
qualitatively different - there really
is no substitute for re interviewing
people in our case sometimes up to more
than half a dozen times and you you you
build the thing in a way that that is
cumulative and extraordinarily rewarding
to do one of the great parts of this
experience for us was the day we had the
conversation in the spring of 2008 about
the book and conceptualized it and then
had a few follow-up conversations the
result the the the conception of what we
wanted to do in the book from those few
early conversations is exactly what we
executed because again we had a hunch
that that kind of book a book that told
the story that way in a narrative form
where everything was accurate and where
we had access to sources across the
board would be a book that people would
still be interested in over a year after
the election let me stop there and hand
over to John yeah you know mark that's
that's a mark I thank you first
professor Brinkley Dean lemon for having
us all thank you again it's an honor to
be here and Mark gives a great overview
of how the book came about I just I
guess I'll add just a couple things to
that and and and then we can move to
questions from the chair and from from
the floor what one of the things is that
as Mark talked about the importance of
characters in the book and and how how
central that was - what animated us and
what we thought was interesting about
the book I mean these were
extraordinarily compelling characters to
the country and and they think in tune
to us as well and and one of the things
that that really in that first
conversation that was compelling to us
was the notion of trying to write a
political book that was not a political
book and we saw these people as and
wanted to portray them as interesting
compelling charismatic
powerful Americans in an incredibly
intense contest but not necessarily as
different from the symbol that those
similar kinds of people who would be
engaged in a similar kind of contest in
other walks of life so you know that
that had a lot of effects in terms of
how we reported the book and wrote the
book we were constantly focused trying
to focus as much as possible on the high
human drama of what this was like I mean
for everybody who went through this it
was an extraordinary race when we
started it was you know we had this
conversation that Mark referred to it
was April of 2008 the Democratic
nomination if I was not yet over and it
was already the longest Democratic
nomination fight that either one of us
had ever covered or that the country had
seen in history and so for Barack Obama
for Hillary Clinton for all the people
around them they had been going through
this incredible marathon for her at that
point sixteen months and you know we
described the the the process in the
book is being kind of a combination
meat-grinder flash incinerator and it's
the kind of thing that really does put
enormous stress on human beings on
marriages on relationships and in the
process of going through it it changed
those characters and those characters
changed in in front and full view of the
country their strengths and weaknesses
as human beings we're very much revealed
their strengths and weaknesses had a
large role to do in what the outcome of
the race was and we were very much
focused on all of that kind of stuff we
had another standing joke which was that
we wanted to try to stay away from all
these things but not just strategists
and and policy and polls even though
again we were very interested in all
those things but there were issues a
process that consumed enormous numbers
of cycles for for many people in our
business we would joke often that if we
would we were absolutely adamant that we
were not going to write about the
seeding of Florida and Michigan
delegation if we could if we wrote the
kind of book in the Democratics on the
Democratic side if we wrote the kind of
book we wanted to write that would not
be in there not because it wasn't
important but because it was the kind of
thing that was covered endlessly during
that during the time of the race and was
the kind of thing that most normal human
beings who were not obsessed with
politics or people who lived with inside
the beltway really cared about and
didn't really have anything to do with
the human experience of the people who
were running but the other thing I'd say
is you know that we often would joke in
in this process in the same way we often
would joke about how one of our cardinal
rules in writing this book and for some
people in publishing this is apparently
a controversial thing but we sort of had
a standing rule which was if it's not
interesting we're not going to put it in
the book and there are there are a lot
of books I think it's fair to say in all
spheres that that feel very padded
because people put in everything from
their notebooks they put him everything
and try to be to dump as much
information into the book into their
books as possible and Mark and I had a
very kind of scrupulous rigorous for you
constantly that if that if the book felt
like it was dragging that the importance
of the propulsion of the narrative was
if it was was high and if the book felt
like it was dragging at any point we
started looking for things to cut we
wanted the book to be to be true and be
accurate and important but also to have
this kind of propulsive effect that
carried you through like it was a novel
although everything and it would be
would be the case it would be to would
have been true factually accurate
the only other thing I'd say and it's
one of the things that's really become
clear I think it was our conviction in
beforehand but it became really clear
how valuable this was afterwards which
is that as we go around the country and
talk to people about the book one of the
things that I think has resonated most
strongly with people is that it's not a
partisan book that the book is not in
much of political publishing now if you
are Sean Hannity or on the right or
Chris Matthews on the left or Keith
Olbermann on the left that is a way that
you can have a commercially successful
political book but if you try to play it
down the middle you're doomed because
they only buy political books apparently
our partisans least that's the
conventional wisdom what we've heard
from people at that we've talked to over
the course of the last four months since
the book came out constantly is people
expressing a kind of gratitude to us for
writing a book that was not partisan
that was not biased that seemed to treat
both sides of the race with with with
fairness and and which group with
scrupulousness with scrupulous fairness
no one we've had people from as far left
as you can be to as far right as you can
be applauded the book and and and and
and find the book satisfying in various
ways and that had attorneys been very
satisfying to us because although both
of us have our power our politics and
our political leanings I think we both
think that
that there's been a corseting and
hyperbolized of the political dialogue
that's taken place as what mark ones
name the freakshow is kind of taken over
where you have this shouting match that
plays out on cable television and in the
pages of a lot of books we would want to
have that kind of shouting match in the
pages of game changing and we were
pretty a hardcore about making sure that
the book betrayed no kind of ideological
bias and I do think that it speaks to
something about where the country is
politically and and where and what
people are looking for yet from the
media that people have found it in fact
enjoyable and gratifying to read a book
that doesn't seem to be coming from some
particular part is in place with that I
will close and we can ask her any
questions as I say from the chair or the
floor well I have just a couple of
questions then I'll just open it up for
everyone else one question I have you I
mean you you rely very heavily on
interviews and I wonder how many of
these interviews occurred during the
campaign and how many of them occurred
afterwards because I would think that
people working campaigns would have a
very different way of talking about it
once the the turmoil the campaign was
over well we did maybe a quarter of the
interviews we didn't introduce into big
into big tranches one was immediately
after the nomination fights ended so
before the national conventions in the
summer so late spring and early summer
and then we did the bulk of the
interviews after the election and I just
quickly say a number of things about
that
one is that the interviews were done
with extraordinarily care in terms of
explaining the ground rules to the
everyone we interviewed we had a little
speech that we would give every time
even when we read weary interviewing
someone we'd meticulously remind them of
the rules and one of the rules was
everything in the interview is for the
book it wouldn't be used before the
election in the case of the interviews
we did before the election and it
wouldn't be used in on the web or in our
magazines or any other way as I said
before we were interviewing in almost
every case not every case but in almost
every case people who one or both of us
knew
quite well and so they had to have that
trust in us particularly in this age
where reporters tend to not have his
close relationships with candidates and
spouses and staff has existed before and
where because of the web there is a
greater danger with some reporters that
you if they've told something that they
might publish it in a way that could
affect the outcome so we didn't really I
don't feel people really held back on us
the biggest challenge really in some
ways again from a craft point of view
was scheduling we were determined to do
all the interviews or almost all the
interviews together and we were dealing
with very busy people even though it was
in that relatively slow period after the
nomination fights we were still doing
people who had a lot to do and after the
election particularly when it came to
the people who were many people who were
going into the government they were
obviously quite busy too and and and all
I can say is what you sent the beginning
of your question but it's heavily based
on interviews almost all of our all of
our writing is directly derivative of
the interviews that we did and and the
book would not exist without the
extraordinary cooperation of over 200
people who saw and felt we were we were
glad to say and lucky that it was an
important project and that you know
campaigns people don't write very much
down and so this was a world history
that would be lost and and and we found
even within for a given individual that
we'd interview them and then we'd
interviewed them later and often they
would forget what they told us or denied
they told us something because their
memories start to corrode and an extract
extraordinarily quick great so we're
very glad and lucky we got done the ones
we were able to do before the election
and then because the timetable were on
we had to do them in a hurry after the
election and both both sets were
extraordinarily important because if
we'd waited until after the election to
interview people about the early part of
the process they would have remembered
far less so the the principal characters
is at least in my view of the book
were obama-clinton Edwards McCain and
Palin I and with the exception of Obama
almost every other candidate I ended up
in some kind of train wreck Edwards may
be maybe the most spectacular of them
but all of those campaigns sort of had a
meltdown and I just wonder why you think
or do you have a sense of is this just a
coincidence that everybody in the
campaign except Obama ran what turned
out to be a really terrible campaign or
is there something about this election
that made it excel and unusually
difficult for people to campaign
effectively I think there's a there's
some truth to both those things
certainly the the the length of the of
the process you know how long these
people had a campaign for was certainly
part of the put a huge amount of stress
on everyone involved that you know the
extraordinary demands of fundraising all
of those factors but you know I think
it's a fair observation to say that they
were all that there are plenty of train
wrecks in those campaigns what's
interesting about them I think at least
from our perspective what was so
interesting about them was the ways in
which the the the train wrecks had
different kind of characters they look
different from campaign to campaign and
they were very much reflective of the of
the candidates themselves you had you
know in the case of in the case of John
McCain Hillary Clinton both you know we
were both I think surprised to report it
to learn as we reported the book just
how ambivalent and how reluctant they
were to get in in the first place and
many of the problems that they had in
the early goings of their campaign
derived directly from their reluctance
they had different reasons for being
reluctant but in some senses there were
they were they were different but also
similar you know John McCain very much
especially in specially Cindy McCain
felt very and felt very burned by the
process in 2000 Cindy McCain not just
reluctant but opposed to her husband
running because of what had happened to
them at the hands they
thought of the Bush campaign in 2000 in
South Carolina very serious perience for
them emotionally John McCain did not
think he would run for president again
and and when he finally did decide to
run was a very awkward and uncomfortable
frontrunner and and much of the of the
disarray in his campaign when his
campaign was at its most disarray --is--
which was in the first six months of
2007 you know came directly out of this
discomfort that McCain had with having
them placed in the role of a
front-runner having this edifice of
frontrunner dun built around him all of
the expectations in terms of fundraising
in terms of building a national a
national organization taking on this
this mantle of in the Republican Party
in particular taking on the mantle of
frontrunner Hood met made him awkward
because he was the guy who very much
preferred to run and in a spirit much
closer to the kind of person he is which
is a bit more of the classic fighter
pilot who's a who's more of a loner more
of a free spirit not someone who likes
structure very much and and he rebelled
against that with terrible consequences
in those first in those early months you
know in Hillary Clinton you see a woman
who in addition to have an ambivalence
about getting in you know had had seen
you know the disarray in her campaign is
obviously evident throughout the book
but you if you look at it as we did in
the book you you see the roots of it she
had had seen in her husband's campaign
in 1992 that a fractious campaign staff
in her view which did not necessarily
lead to defeat she didn't see fractious
nough sand and conflict as a problem and
in fact looking at the 92 model she saw
that a certain amount of creative energy
could come out of that kind of conflict
and so she almost intentionally built a
campaign in which conflict was at the
core and her her notion of a campaign
staff that was a team of rivals this
notion that the people around her would
be strong personalities who would duke
it out and the best ideas would arise
among them was very much today about a
purposeful one was what she tried to
model her campaign on what she didn't
seem to recognize was that in such a
model what's required is a leader at the
top who eventually adjudicates between
the competing ideas and chooses a clear
path forward something she was always
very reluctant to do
and goes I think to some of the some of
the weaknesses in her character that the
book exposes and that really plagued her
campaign and plagued her her whole her
whole run for the presidency you know we
could talk about the what happened later
in terms of the Sarah Palin thing but
there's no better example of a place
where the the the personal foible of a
candidate were more clearly played out
in the trainwreck quality of his
campaign than what John Edwards
certainly and you know one of the themes
I think that comes through in the book
and you can see it in all of these
cabinet candidates to some extent is
this gap between public image and
private reality one of the things that
Mark and I heard over and over again
with respect to John Edwards and also in
particular with his wife Elizabeth was
that the gap between their public image
and their private reality was greater
than it was for any other two people in
American public life and the process of
trying to manage that gap and this is
one of the places where Obama well I had
a huge asset in the fact that his public
image at private reality were much
closer than they were from any of the
other candidates in Edwards this case
the attempt to manage that discord was
all-consuming for his campaign and and
for and indeed trying to manage it for
in terms of his wife and you can see
very clearly in the book the
consequences of that for for how he ran
and and I think there there was you know
there's something to be said for for the
notion that character is destiny but
character is also organization and make
kind of the organizations that arise
around these people very much reflect
their characters and that's one of the
kind of key lessons in the book well let
me invite any of you who want to to ask
a question I don't know if there if
there are microphone oh there are
microphones perhaps we don't need them
but yeah
oh that's right guess we're being
recorded so yeah please come up to the
microphone a glance at the book at the
booksellers table and I looked up Rudy
Giuliani and tried to find out why his
campaign fizzled and pages 288 289 and
300 and essentially you give four or so
reasons the governor chris is an
endorsement of McCain Rudy's wife a
couple of other factors his poor
performance and debates and of course
Bernard Kerik my question is have you
gotten any feedback from Rudy directly
or indirectly as to whether he thought
your analysis of the failure of his
campaign was right on or not thank you
well I'd say I'd say some good indirect
confirmation was his endorsement of
Marco Rubio a few days ago in the
Florida Senate race and he said I mean
more direct and indirect he said when he
endorsed Rubio amongst the reasons he
was endorsing was because of his
experience with governor Governor Crist
in the in the endorsement process
because it was you write in the book
just in a classic story of how politics
works a governor Crist was not seen as a
trustworthy figure even by John McCain
who reinvention alia endorsed because he
promised McCain his endorsement very
early on and the governor floored
although he's more famous now because of
the trouble he's having than he was back
then even as the governor of Florida as
a big endorsement probably the biggest
of any of any politician in the country
because of the importance of the Florida
primary and Governor Chris ability to
raise money so he promised McCain as
endorsement McCain had had taken a risk
by endorsing Chris in his primary when
he was running for governor and Giuliani
did not and Giuliani sort of felt he'd
missed the opportunity there Chris
McCain felt that he was going to get
Chris endorsement just as McCain had
endorsed president and crisp held back
and didn't promise it and in fact move
very close
to endorse a Giuliani so on that on that
story I think I think it's safe to say
that the mayor agrees with our narrative
and and and and and the fact that they
thought they were getting the
endorsement of Kristen staked a lot of
their strategy on it is something that
I'm certain he agrees with no he didn't
say was tricked okay Becky he no he also
he also said that that he thought Rubio
was a better candidate for the party me
he did he explicitly said it wasn't the
only reason but it was kind of unusual I
thought because he could have simply hid
behind a range of all the reasons that a
lot of people are endorsing Rubio now
including the fact that he looks like
he's you know he's 20 points plus ahead
so he did say was the only reason but it
was pretty striking that he said it was
a reason you know a lot of the people
who we wrote about in the book have
explicitly reacted and and and some have
said like Elizabeth Edwards that it that
stuff in the book about her is true the
mayor hasn't challenged it the other
things we wrote and I'd say the mayor is
not one who shiz from challenging
including people in our business so I
won't say that that means he endorses
everything in it but look a lot of the
interviews we did to create the portions
about the mayor which aren't that long
because he's not a major character in
the book we're based on interviews with
people very close to him and very
supportive of him to this day
and so the the narrative is not based on
people with axes to grind or hostility
so as we are with everything else in the
book the genetic stuff were quite fully
confident that it's accurate
guys you mentioned some of the
characters pre-existing flaws as they
came into the campaign but also how some
of their characteristics have changed
over the campaign could you elaborate on
that on the case of Obama for example
that it would have changed over the 16
months ago well I think you know Obama's
maybe the maybe one of the more striking
examples I mean we one of the things
that you know although mark and I had
had covered the the race in the very
beginning one of the things that was
very striking in the course of going
back and excavating the material that we
did for the book was just kind of how
bad a candidate Obama was in 2007 and
you know I the the the badness of his
the superficial elements of why he was a
poor candidate were pretty evident for a
lot of people to see at the time at
least because poor performance in the
debates was widely noted that he lost
you know if any to him by his
acknowledgement his campaigns
acknowledgement he he pretty much had
the floor wiped with him by Hillary
Clinton potentially at the floor with
him throughout 2007 he was not for a lot
of that year he was not the
inspirational orator that many people
expected him to be given that their
first impressions of him were from the
2004 Democratic convention where he'd
given this incredible speech which
really launched his national political
career I think some of those things you
you see that they are rooted in in in in
a something you actually still see in
Obama now as president which is a
certain version to the the artifice of
politics you know he he knew that there
was a certain amount of performance
involved in politics as every political
candidate does but I think you know much
of what he tried to do in 2007 was
rooted in a commendable interest in
trying to conduct an adult conversation
with the nomination electorate so you
would have Obama going to town hall
meetings and conducting very
professorial often quite dull long
disquisitions on various aspects of
policy in his debate performances his
biggest problems that he was always
trying to shove too much information in
answer you know his and he would say
this and as we report in the book he
would say this in debate prep you know
well I have 60 seconds for that answer
how much can I get in which is the you
know the the kind of classic tendency of
someone who's a very smart guy who wants
to answer the question completely it
wants to show off his knowledge but not
someone who's necessarily focused on on
making the most effective presentation
in that setting and so I think one of
the things that you see as Obama becomes
gradually throughout the book a much
better politician you see someone
learning a trade you know learning a
craft and and making certain kinds of
compromises of what he thinks of as the
ideal way for a candidate to run in the
interests of becoming a better candidate
a more effective candidate one who
connects better with with with people
out in the in the country and I think
that change you see it manifests itself
over the course of 11 months in in the
course of 2007 and from really from the
early part of November of 2007 when he
gave this famous speech in Iowa at the
Jefferson Jackson dinner through the key
moments of the nomination fight the
direct nomination fight with Hillary
Clinton in the in the winter of 2008 you
can see him growing into himself as a as
a public figure and as a politician and
and and and learning to make the kind of
compromises that you need to make
between the ideal of what you would like
to present and and the reality of what
actually works in a hotly contested
presidential campaign hello my name is
milena thank you very much for coming
and speaking with us I read game change
for my American politics class and
really enjoyed it I was following the
campaign thank you by that book were
doing as a reserve reading but I I
worked on the Obama campaign in Florida
and certainly election night was the
climax for for us and for everyone
watching the election and the book
however I feel didn't pose election
night as the climax of the the narrative
and as I'm wondering about your
treatment of that what what what
decision-making went into that thank you
well that's a it's a good example of you
know John mentioned before the see
the Florida and mission delegations
because of the fight over the rules is
something we were bad not to include
things like election night and and other
big set-piece events were so familiar to
the country there are almost iconic
moments that we were we asked around
about him and we reported on them but we
couldn't really advance that as a story
the emotion involved the facts of them
were so well known that including them
in a book of the length were doing not a
comprehensive book in a sense of every
event including the big events detail
than ever in particular was too much for
us it just it would have been too long
so we had some little nice things about
election night in Chicago but but it
didn't fit with our premise about how to
make that how to make the book an
interesting and people will occasionally
say to us events just like that you know
why didn't you include more on acts and
again it was a pretty simple test to go
back to what John said if we couldn't
write about in an interesting way if it
didn't fit with being revealing about
about the candidate a candidate or a
spouse it didn't fit with what we were
doing you may want to add to that well I
just like that you know I think though
we we made it we made a very conscious
choice about it and you know the book
has a relatively lengthy narration of
the last day of Obama's campaign which I
think for both of us felt like the
emotional climax in a lot of ways for
what he was living through the the there
was no question by that day day where I
happen to be among the two of us I
happen to be traveling with him that day
was a very extraordinary emotional day
his it was you know we hadn't dealing
with the the the death of his
grandmother and and and he was but but
there was no question in anyone's mind
that he was going to win at that point
the the drama of victory had kind of
been drained away and what there was was
a this other kind of drama but this
human drama of him of him going through
that last day living through this kind
of extraordinary emotional rollercoaster
closing the campaign in that way felt in
some ways more climax
and particularly as mark to go back to
what Marcus said you know that the lot
the speech the last night in Virginia
having seen both of them the speech on
election that was an extraordinary
speech but in some ways it was that it
was the the first speech of the new
administration rather than the last
speech of the campaign and and because
we were also with the exception with a
sole exception of our description of
Hillary Clinton Barack Obama and there
are negotiations over Secretary of State
because that was such an important
emotional and psychological in the book
we really kind of wanted to end the book
on on what felt like the end of the
campaign and not and not be casting
forward into the new administration and
if you remember the speech on election
night as emotional as well as for a lot
of people in the crowd one of the things
about it was that it was a very sober
speech and not an exultant speech and
not a speech about victory so much as it
was a speech about the the new
responsibilities that were now on his
shoulders going forward a very powerful
speech but a speech that come out kind
of thematic alee didn't feel as much
like closure as the as the one the night
before in Virginia had
my name is Cristian I'm a student here
at the journalism school said a question
I was wondering if you at any point
we're concerned that the book might kind
of skew unfairly in favor of Obama in
that you know people who worked on the
Obama campaign we're at where afterwards
mostly working in government therefore
might be less likely to kind of dish the
dirt on the campaign as someone perhaps
was in the McCain campaign would be
never once and again I'll go back to
something I think I've said twice now
which is because we know these people
you know I won't say I won't say the
portrait of Barack Obama is negative but
there are I'd say as tough things about
him and how he dealt with people you
know our portrayal of him as as almost
anybody has written about him but from
an objective journalistic point of view
and again I'll use the phrase if that
appears in some of the critiques of our
book this notion of talking people with
an axe to grind we didn't put anything
in the book that was based on only on
sources who were felt negatively towards
the person they were talking about the
reality of the other portraits is there
is the reality of what happened based on
talking to people some people who may be
having quote-unquote axe to grind but
but also people still very favorably
disposed towards the people they were
talking about and you know if we had
gone and tried to write a book about
like this and this style interviewing
about an area we don't know as much
about show business or Gore or Wall
Street we'd be starting from scratch
with people and trying to evaluate them
but one of the responsibilities of a
journalist and and and methods if you're
doing it right is to be able to evaluate
people not every sentence from source a
and source B should be treated the same
way you've got to put it in the context
of who they are and what they think and
what they feel so there's no question
that the portrayal of Barack Obama is is
it comes off as a better guy than John
Edwards but I think the country probably
has a pretty firm agreement at this
point that he is in many ways a better
guy than John Edwards in most guys and
and I don't I don't think read in its
totality that I hope at least that the
portrayals of anybody are unfair I think
they're all fair and and and complete
and based on again a lot of interviews
and and with as John said before a real
effort to be not just scrupulously fair
in terms of accuracy but not partisan or
or taking cheap shots of anybody I can
Favreau a couple months ago you may have
seen it Peggy Noonan did a column in her
weekend did it published one of her
columns on the weekend in the Wall
Street Journal and it was her reaction
to reading your book and if I read her
correctly her takeaway was these are not
noble people in a noble pursuit and so
kind of a two-part question one is do
you did I read her correctly and to do
you agree with that assessment well I as
I remember that column and I confess
that my memory is not perfect but I I
thought her poem war was that everyone
in the book was crazy and it wasn't a
question so much about nobility or
ignoble 'ti is about insanity insanity
and I to the extent that I look I don't
think that that you can put yourself
through this process without a certain
amount of lunacy you know and and
certainly a lot of you know all of these
candidates have this mixture of
qualities they are all to some degree
very needy they are all to some degree
quite grandiose there's an enormous
amount of ego and vanity in in all and
anybody who thinks or purports to be
suitable to being president United
States it's certainly true also that
some very extreme that in some of the
cases of some of these candidates in
that you see in the book there's some
very extreme and behavior that that
strikes one as being a little unhinged
at times and and I I think Mark and I
both put that down to the extraordinary
pressure that these people were under
throughout the course of the campaign
but
amidst all of those qualities that I
just mentioned and amidst all that and
some of that behavior that seems a
little as I say a little unhinged you
know I think there's also an enormous
amount of and I know mark agrees there's
an enormous amount of nobility involved
in in in the pursuit of this office and
in in in the pursuit of public service I
think that at the core of what drives
all these people is the desire to try to
make the country better and and they and
they may be ego maniacs that think that
they're the person who's best able to
deliver that but there is a nobility to
it most of them could be making a lot
more money doing something else and
instead they decide to put themselves in
in the you know in a situation of
extraordinary scrutiny where it's very
hard to have a normal personal life very
hard to have a normal marriage very hard
to have a normal family life under the
relentless glare of the media and
they're doing it largely because they
think that they have a vision for how to
make the country better so I think it's
a mixed bag but amid the the many
qualities they have and and some some
qualities that are not so so so pleasant
or pretty there's also this this core
degree that's very very honorable and
very noble and I think that's true of
really everybody in the book I don't
even even the candidates even some of
the ones who who in in our book who who
come off the worst I don't think that I
think there is somewhere deep down there
even in John Edwards there's a core of
nobility about having done what he did
in trying to run for president twice I
just had one one thing on a point I feel
really strong about did John and I both
care a lot about our business as a as a
business we want journalism to be able
to succeed in as a commercial enterprise
but we also care about the standards of
our business and we knew if the book had
any success whatsoever that people would
scrutinize the methods we used in all
sorts of ways how we did the interviews
the tone of the book how we treated the
characters and and one thing that I
think is incredibly important is we can
be cynical like most people and most
journalists but we did not approach the
characters in a cynical way we know them
all and have covered them all and and
some better than others but but have an
appreciation for all of them as people
and and the fact that they do put
themselves forward to do this incredibly
difficult thing physically taxing very
hard on themselves and their family and
so you
cynicism can be in the eye of the
beholder but but we really tried to
write about them all with empathy and
with understanding for what they were
facing rather than what a lot of
journalism a lot of political journalism
is now which is very cynical and and
questioning the motives of people all
the time I'd say just just to single her
out because I think it may be the
clearest example is Hillary Clinton
someone who we both know and have
covered for a long time
some of the earliest readers of the book
were people who before it was published
a few people who showed it to where
people who weren't particularly
favorably disposed towards her and had a
pretty cynical view of her and they felt
many of them came away with a view a
more favorable view of a broader
understanding of her and and we hope we
did that for every character but that
was certainly our goal and to not treat
them as people who were unworthy or
unknowable ignoble or or or in it in
this simply to amass power or to order
to feed their ego I'm a second year at
SEPA and I was just wondering from a
journalism a journalist point of view
why you think Obama was so effective at
getting his message across as a
candidate and then not so much in his
first year of office well there are a
couple different answers that question I
would first refer back to an answer that
I gave a little while ago which is that
I think it's it's true that for much of
2007 it's it's it's a trick of the
memory too soon that Obama was effective
at getting his message at for much of
that year and and you know when when we
looked up at in in October of 2007 and
Hillary Clinton was ahead by 30 points
in the national polls there were an
awful lot of Democrats and some people
inside Obama's world who felt that he
was not succeeding at all in getting his
message across and that he had been
actually yet he was in fact the problem
that the campaign had extraordinary
success in terms of fundraising
extraordinary success in terms of
organization that the can't but the
campaign was extraordinarily good and
the candidate himself was not that good
and particularly on the question of
having of having a message that was that
was that was effective
both a positive message in a negative
message it's certainly the case I mean
if you want to go into the weeds about
about a little bit into the weeds I mean
one of the things that made Obama so
effective in terms of his message when
he got when he became effective and as
we plant we paint it very much in the
book was when the moment would came when
he decided to effectively go negative
against Hillary Clinton without really
trying to went out without looking
negative and a lot of that was rooted in
the fact that the people around Obama
were great students of the Clintons some
of them had worked for the Clintons had
seen had access to two to data having
worked for the Clintons that knew where
that they knew where the soft underbelly
was of Hillary Clinton and of her
husband to a large extent and they were
very astute and careful in being able to
craft a message that framed Hillary
Clinton in very negative terms without
ever really attacking her in a
straightforward way Obama was very good
at speaking in code in ways that would
raise many doubts and and and stir lots
of some of the negative feelings that
many Democrats had about the Clintons
without ever feeling as though he was
like taking a meat axe to her that that
when he finally got there that degree of
precision and subtlety was was hugely
important within the Democratic primary
a nomination audience the nomination
electorate I think that the broader
question though that goes to the
question of today you know mark often
says that that then I agree with this
that presidential candidates do exactly
as much as they need to do to get
elected and and not one iota more than
what they need to do and in it seen from
30,000 feet a lot of what this election
was was Obama in the nomination battle
having to be not a Clinton and then in
the general election trying to be trying
to present himself as not not a very
difficult task but present himself as
not a bush or someone who looked like
bush or was a bush inheritor or a bush a
bush clone as they painted successfully
John McCain what what what he did not
have to do unfortunately for him I think
was do something that Bill Clinton in
1992 and Ronald Reagan in 1980 did
extraordinarily well which was to take a
a very clear ideological set of
ideological convictions that they had
come to over the course of 20 years of
kind of marinating in the juices of
their party's debates take that that
core set of convictions and marry them
up to the set of policies they proposed
and put together a theory of the case
you know or a narrative about where the
country was how the their their merger
of of core conviction and policy was the
how to knit that together to make a
coherent story about how that was the
right thing to take the country forward
Obama never really had to do that and he
succeeded without having done it I think
it actually was has been proud was been
problematic for him in his first 15 or
16 months in office
I don't think so far that we can say
Obama's been a failure he's that
difficult theses had some huge successes
but one thing that is notable is that to
the extent that he has problems is that
he is in the in the odd position of
having most of among his supporters of
having people who are on the left side
of the Democratic Party think that he is
an appeasing centrist and people are on
the centrist on the centrist side of
democratic party think that he's gone
far too far to the left there's a
profound confusion still among I think
the country at large and certainly even
among Democrats who really want the
president's to succeed there's still a
great confusion about who he is what his
project is for the country what Obama
ISM represents and I think it goes back
to this fact that he didn't have to do
that during the during the campaign that
he didn't have to spell that out in a
very clear and compelling way and I
think that that it is it would behoove
him and he would it would help him
politically if he were able to do that
in a more clear concise and compelling
way that he's had to do so far or that
he has been able to do so far mr.
Halpern I just like to I'm Jeff Roberts
- journalism student here I'd like to
speak briefly about your experience
going from ABC the note to the page a
new sort of multimedia gambits I admire
enormous geopolitical analysis but
sometimes I get a bit suspect of your
sort of motives it's a journalist but
it's nothing new sometimes you what I'm
not being cute I did sometimes you get I
sometimes wonder about your motives as a
journalist but you are very good at what
you do but it seems you've almost
invented
branding yourself as a journalist across
different platforms what do you suspect
me of I'm serious I'd love to know okay
um I I had a nice question I swear I
mean is it okay if it's on it's on
opportunism sometimes because with a
will to win I mean you seems you know
pumping for Karl Rove and friends and
the switch they always seem to be on the
winning side
but your political analysis is the best
on the web so but my question is
actually if you can just please describe
the transition to the page what you see
working in the business of journalism
video or online or you seem to be one of
the first to go across all the platforms
sir alright well I won't I won't risk
boring everyone with talking to you
about my motives and and my journalism
unless unless you want to follow with
that audience or your other question I
think that being journalists the most
important thing in whatever platform you
want to be on is learning how to write
even if you're in broadcast knowing how
to write is really the every journalism
student I ever speak to or the student
did any in any business you want to be
in but certainly in journalism knowing
how to write is really the most
important thing I think that the the
reality is you know ABC News where I
worked for 20 years wants to be in the
print business because they want a
successful website that requires a lot
of print content and Time magazine wants
to be in the streaming video business
because they know that there's gonna be
more revenue that comes with with that
increasing consumer interest in video on
the web so there's not a news
organization in the country big news
organization and even a smaller ones
where there's not a great interest in in
in content that runs the gamut from
print audio and video and graphics and I
think anybody who wants to be a
journalist today wherever they want to
work you need to you need to be have a
lot of different skills you need to be a
utility player and excelled as many
things as you can and you do need to
have your own brand because that is the
way things succeed these days it's
always been to some extent true at ABC
News when I was there
at the beginning Roone Arledge was
incredibly sophisticated at finding
brands like barbara walters david
brinkley peter jennings ted koppel to to
be brands within the ABC brand and and
the best brands individual brands are
ones that are excellent at produce
content that consumers are interested in
and have a relationship with the larger
corporate or institutional brands in
which they're working and I think to the
extent I've had success in two different
places it's because I think they're both
places that value quality content and I
hope I'm producing quality content and
and also a use of a medium in this case
in both the cases you cited the web
where you take advantage of the medium
to appeal to advertisers and to
consumers rather than feeling the medium
is a burden or something that you have
to do because it's a medium that exists
and and requires content and so both of
those products I conceived of because I
thought they would they would find an
audience in that medium and and I felt I
could produce that content competitively
against other people
hi I had one of the things I'm most most
interested in in journalism is media
analysis and criticism and what I found
remarkably fascinating after the
election was a panel that you two were
both on it I think the end of November
where you said that this election was or
the media coverage of this election was
the most abject failure since the
invasion of Iraq in terms of the probe
on the bias for whatever reason I think
that there was a John head so that there
was an intelligence factor in the
campaign and I was just wondering where
do you see the media now right stand
aside while I answer so I can make eye
contact the previous pressure so you're
saying this was a case where guy just
been elected president of the United
States it's an extraordinarily powerful
position and he's coming into office and
I went out and I said that the coverage
of him during the campaign was too soft
and was a big failure so this was not a
case where I was sucking up to somebody
who was ascending or siding with the
winners right right you know I know it's
just just food for thought for you for
your
for your point yeah I've got to defend
myself I like your work the only reason
this was in my head was cuz I first
discovered you with the note and I was a
bit of an ingenue and I swore you were
like a Coll Rove like Mandarin and then
my boss who was a PR person said no no
no he's in the tank with the Clintons
yeah and then you put on this book and
someone appears accusing you working for
Obama so you're probably doing something
right I've got a recent example of that
I'll tell you afterwards cuz you've got
a particular interest but I won't bore
everybody oh you know John and I both
felt that there was a that there and
other people have said that the coverage
of Obama was too soft and and if you if
you press David Axelrod Robert Gibbs or
give them two martinis they would admit
that and there's a variety of reasons
for that he was the best story he had
good relations with reporters he was
running in the case of the Clintons
against someone against a couple who the
press had turned on long ago in almost
every instance and then against McCain
someone who used to be a darling of the
press but because he disappointed a lot
of reporters including some liberal
reporters he was seen almost in a more
negative way than than a typical
Republican so I don't think there's any
doubt that in every cycle one candidate
rises above the others maybe not
throughout the cycle but during periods
where they're getting really softer
coverage for a variety of reasons some
some understandable and maybe even
justified in some not in this case I
think again I think by any objective
standard Barack Obama got coverage that
that was not as tough John has said and
I agree with him that Clinton and and
McCain got tough coverage but it wasn't
overly tough the scrutiny was was what
it should have been it's just Obama
never got tough scrutiny in the way in
the way that they did about his
background about his qualifications and
and you know the Clintons in particular
felt really strongly about it and and it
got inside their heads and kind of
discombobulated them so it had a
spillover effect not just Obama getting
software coverage but the Clintons
really becoming a little unhinged over
it in a way that affected their
performance yeah I would I mean I I
would only add to that just that you
know there's a
you know for every presidential camp
candidate you know the the the care and
feeding of your public image is one of
the central supreme objectives and goals
that you have and part of doing that
well is recognizing how narratives work
how kind of meta narratives that are out
there in the press how that works and
and part of that is not just recognizing
what your positive narrative is and then
pushing that but also recognizing what
negative stereotypes might exist about
you in the press and avoiding those
things for McCain and for Clinton they
seemed either in many cases to either be
blind to to those negative stereotypes
or they understood them but still
continued to do things that fed those
stereotypes rather than been blunting
them I'm one of the things that I mean I
give the Obama campaign credit in some
sense because they're there there was
not just that the press for the reasons
mark said was inclined to be softer and
more favorable to Obama though I think
it was but the Obama campaign recognized
except that in you know and stoked those
flames in a very in a very crafty way in
some cases and managed to steer the
press towards the negative narratives
about their rivals and steer them away
from some of the possibly possible
vulnerabilities around Obama's own
narrative so the management of press
relations that in terms of the quality
and skill between the three campaigns
was markedly different and the Obama
campaign not only got more favorable
coverage but had a very strong hand in
engineering that that coverage and to
the point of the marks initial to joke
about about about Robert Givens and
David Axelrod and how they would admit
this under under earth under threat of
perjury or under the influence of
alcohol you know there is a scene in the
book I think that speaks to this as
clearly as almost anything does you know
we're on the day before the Texas and
Ohio primaries Obama is in the middle of
one of the periodic spasms around around
town as Coe and he does a media
availability I can't remember exactly
where
one of those two states where he is we
have at the time when we saw this happen
we thought it was a moment in the
campaign that was rather extraordinary
and then looking back on it we thought
it was more of a moment but where he's
asked he's stood up in an immediate Bell
ability and he's asked four or five or
six questions and he answers each one of
them in a kind of perfunctory way and as
he's about to walk away having answered
all of five questions was it five five
questions he walked he's about to walk
away from the podium and there's this
group of reporters who were very upset
about the fact that this is a big news
day there's some Resco related news that
they want to ask him about and he's
basically just blown them off completely
he's walking away from the podium and
they're all yelling what you can't leave
you can't leave you you need to answer
our questions and he very frustrated Lee
with this attitude with this look of
complete dismay on his face as if it was
ridiculous that anyone could be treating
him this way services guys come on I
just answered like five questions and
you think about a presidential
candidates who by that point brocco bomb
was the front-runner in the Democratic
race you know frontrunner scrutiny
generally has kicked in long before then
and you've become acquainted with the
notion of the fact that you can't just
stand up in front of a media
availability your first one in probably
two weeks and blow off reporters that
egregiously and then you know just walk
away and have that and expect them not
to press you in fact not only did he not
expect that but he actually got
flustered and kind of upset and peevish
about the fact that he was being treated
that way and I think it actually went it
spoke to at that moment just how unused
to that far into the campaign how unused
to the notion of being treated in a
halfway aggressive way that he was in
terms of the press and you know you
still there there are other examples
that's probably the most vivid you still
in some case it I think it's one of the
things that's been hardest for him
getting used to as president is that
he's finally started to get scrutiny
that's appropriate to the to the office
or the position that he has in the
political world and just to go back to
your question I had to add that into one
reason he was more successful as a
candidate he's now not only getting
tougher coverage from this quote-unquote
mainstream press which he almost never
got as a candidate and he's never gotten
it it's like no one in our lifetimes or
our professional careers at least have
gotten to the White House with such
little negative coverage and he's now
getting attacked by the right-wing freak
show which happened some during the
campaign but it's much broader it has a
much bigger audience and you know McCain
kept some of the right-wing media
oregon's from really going after Obama
because they're too busy going after him
they were too busy going after him and
they were so I'm bit about him and about
the contest and and Barack Obama was
rising above some of the some of the
things that are devil any Democratic
president now now he's not and he's not
used to it he doesn't much like it and
he's much more like Bill Clinton and and
to some extent George Bush according to
people close to him where he now says
things like the press doesn't understand
me the press never gives me credit for
what I've accomplished he never had to
deal with that in the campaign last
question it was mentioned earlier
Giuliani's endorsement of marco rubio
and it was interesting that this was
mentioned because a lot of commentators
in florida among them George Bernie of
the Palm Beach Post have written how
sometimes almost jokingly but how
despite the differences in ideology the
campaign's of Marco Rubio and Barack
Obama are very similar in the narrative
sue percent like to both the son of an
immigrant they're both the underdog and
in terms of endorsement it was also true
that in the beginning Obama didn't have
as many as many endorsements and now
Marco Rubio's well he's getting a lot
more endorsements now that he's a
leading so I was wondering if you share
this view and if you believe that there
so sort of almost conscious effort by
Rubio to imitate some aspects of Obama's
campaign the short answer is yes you
know particularly this notion which is
very hard to do and they're both very
good at it of being for change that's
relatively easy being against the
establishment but being optimistic I
think I think Marco Rubio has become
like Scott Brown is vessel into which
much too much as being poured in terms
of both what they've done and what it
means and also their possibility as
national candidates but Marco Rubio has
n Scott Brown both are able to talk
Republican ideas and conservative ideas
and about changing the status quo while
still being optimistic the way Ronald
Reagan could the way Bill Bill Clinton
could the way Barack Obama could and I
think I think that similarity is is is
not just natural I think Rubio has has
adopted some of that in a way that that
is very shrewd and I add only to that
that you know one of the one of the
dynamics that really comes through in
game change is that you pointed out that
that at the beginning Hillary Clinton
had more endorsements and bravo obama
had fewer we know we report in the book
how much of the establishment was
actually you know behind obama but just
secretly behind obama that they wanted
the Clintons to lose and they were
waiting for the right moment where it
was safe to come out and and be for
Obama there's a certain similarity in in
this case also because there was I think
it has been revealed as the Republican
establishment has moved into Rubio's
column is not just that they're moving
there because he's a winner but also
they had very little loyalty to charlie
Crist
and although they might not have been
secretly rooting for Rubio though the
making of ending up in that column it's
not a painful thing for them because
their loved the level of loyalty that
they had to Governor Crist was it was
not high to begin with and I think
there's a certain similarity there
between the way the Democratic
establishment wasn't that was ostensibly
for the Clintons but in fact on a deeper
level had no real ties to them and
didn't particularly care if Hillary
Clinton won or in fact what about
actually preferred for her to lose well
let me just say we're before we stop by
it seems to me that the campaign books
are a kind of genre that is fairly new
starting maybe in 1960 with Theodore
White's
that making the president 1960 and in
that book the focus was was on John
Kennedy and Richard Nixon I and they
were treated with great reverence in
that book but it nevertheless was a book
about the candidates and there were
other characters but that was really
what the book was about and you look
forward a few years and starting with
maybe Joe McGinnis campaign books start
to be about the handlers
and about the tactician Xand maybe the
most obvious example of this is the the
war room the the documentary about the
Clinton campaign in which Clinton makes
cameo appearances in the in the very
beginning and then is rushed off the
stage it's all Stephanopoulos and and
Carville and with maybe the exception of
Richard Ben Kramer I can't think of a a
campaign book after 1968 that really
took the candidates themselves entirely
seriously I think your book did I think
your book sort of returns to the
candidates and I think that's a very
healthy thing and I think we've heard
tonight
a lot of very interesting questions
about candidates rather than about
tactics and strategies of campaign
handlers so thank you both for coming
very much I thank all of you for coming
there are books in the back that I I
suspect the authors would be willing to
sign thank you thank you thank you very
much
you